[Orientalische Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es etwas Herzhaftes zum Ramadan,
nämlich einen Eintopf.
Murat hat sich Etli Patates Yemeği gewünscht,
also einen Fleisch-Kartoffel-Eintopf.
Meine Mama macht das Ganze immer mit ihrem Schnellkochtopf,
muss ich sagen – da geht es auch sehr schnell.
Ich mache das Ganze im Gusseisentopf und dann im Backofen.
Eintöpfe mag ich besonders gern,
weil ich sie sehr gut vorbereiten kann.
Ich kann den Backofen nutzen und muss dann nicht ständig rühren.
Daher ist es super geeignet.
Ich mache das Ganze immer so, dass es auch relativ wässrig ist,
also wirklich wie so ein Eintopf und Suppe in einem.
Gerade zum Ramadan passt es ganz gut.
Vor allem könnt ihr Gemüse, was ihr gerade dahabt
oder was ihr noch verwerten wollt.
Das ist jetzt praktisch nur so mein Rezeptvorschlag für euch
und ihr könnt einfach noch dazugeben, was ihr möchtet.
Dafür nehme ich 1 kg Rind – da könnt ihr z. B. Gulasch verwenden -,
2 EL Butterschmalz, 2 Knoblauchzehen
– ich habe jetzt 2 große; ihr könnt auch 4 ganz normale nehmen -,
1 Zwiebel, 1 EL Mehl, Minze und Bergbohnenkraut und ein Lorbeerblatt,
1 EL Paprikamark, 3 EL Tomatenmark.
Hier habe ich noch ein bisschen Gemüse,
nämlich 1 Karotte, 2 grüne Paprikaschoten, 2 rote Paprikaschoten,
etwas Wasser und 800 g geschälte Kartoffeln, Salz und Pfeffer.
Ihr könnt hier entweder Rind oder auch Lamm nehmen.
Wie gesagt, habe ich jetzt hier Rind.
Ich habe das Ganze, wie gesagt, schon fein zu Gulasch geschnitten.
Jetzt nehme ich das Butterschmalz
und erwärme es in meinem Gusseiseneintopf
- in meinem Gusseisentopf; es wird gleich ein Eintopf.
[Musik]
Solange das Fett noch warm wird,
kann ich schon einmal die Knoblauchzehen und die Zwiebel schälen
und fein würfeln.
[Musik]
Dann könnt ihr das Fleisch in etwa 2 Portionen anbraten,
immer kurz, bis es rundherum schön Röstaromen hat.
Ich gebe nie zu viel Fleisch auf einmal in die Pfanne,
weil ansonsten das eher kocht und ich möchte ja, dass es anbrät.
Deswegen lasse ich immer die Hälfte da
und hole das Fleisch auch immer rechtzeitig aus dem Kühlschrank,
dass es einfach nicht kühlschrankkalt ist,
sondern eher Raumtemperatur hat.
[Bratgeräusche]
Einfach von allen Seiten anbraten und herausnehmen
und in der Zwischenzeit schön weiterschneiden.
[Musik]
Die Karotte schäle ich jetzt auch und schneide sie klein.
Die Paprika schneide ich dann eher in große Würfel.
[Musik und Bratgeräusche]
Jetzt habe ich das Fleisch herausgeholt.
Im Restfett kann ich jetzt die Zwiebel- und Knoblauchwürfel anbraten.
Da jetzt gern die Hitze ein bisschen herunterstellen,
dass es nicht gleich verbrennt.
Also Fleisch brate ich schon immer bei hoher Hitze,
aber Gemüse und Zwiebel bei eher niedriger Hitze.
Einfach 3-4 Minuten, bis sie schön glasig sind.
Damit nicht immer das ganze Haus danach riecht,
mache ich gern auch einfach den Deckel zu.
Was kann ich noch tun?
Ich kann noch die Kartoffeln schneiden.
Die lasse ich jetzt auch relativ groß,
da ich das Gericht im Ofen dann fertiggare.
Ich werde sie jetzt so einfach vierteln und dann halbieren.
Dann habe ich sie wie Wedges, nur halbiert.
[Musik]
So sieht es schon einmal super aus!
Da gebe ich jetzt das Tomaten- und Paprikamark dazu.
Das habe ich übrigens immer auf Vorrat, auch eingefroren,
weil wir entweder aus der Türkei oft Tomatenmark bekommen
- von Freunden oder Verwandten –
oder wir das Ganze im türkischen Supermarkt kaufen.
Da kriegt man immer große Gläser.
Ich verbrauche jetzt auch selbst nicht so viel.
Deswegen friere ich sie gern in Eiswürfelbehältern einfach ein
und kann dann immer das Ganze portionsweise herausholen.
Das kurz mit anbraten, genauso wie das Mehl und die Gewürze.
Wie gesagt,
habe ich jetzt Minze, Bergbohnenkraut und ein Lorbeerblatt
- auch schön mit anbraten.
[Musik]
Dann mit Wasser ablöschen und kurz aufkochen lassen.
Jetzt könnt ihr sie an dieser Stelle mit Salz und Pfeffer würzen.
Da ruhig jetzt ordentlich Salz hinein,
denn das Fleisch ist noch ungewürzt,
die Kartoffel und alles andere ist ja auch ungewürzt.
[Musik]
Ich sag’s dir, das war sogar noch zu wenig Salz,
aber im Video sieht es immer nach so viel aus.
Deswegen traue ich mich nicht im Video nachzuwürzen.
JOSH: Nein, würze mal!
SALLY: Darf ich?
JOSH: Ja!
Wisst ihr,
was ich oft mache, damit die Gewürzmühlen unten nicht so verkleben?
Jetzt kocht sie noch nicht ganz, aber wenn es kocht,
dann verklebt es ziemlich schnell.
Dann mach ich das immer hier auf so einem Teller.
Dann hat man auch immer ein bisschen besser Kontrolle über das Gewürz
und dann hinein.
Gut. Sobald es kocht, den Herd ausschalten.
Dann kommt das Fleisch hinein.
Ich habe das ja nur kurz angebraten – innen ist es noch roh,
aber das Anbraten bewirkt, dass ich diese Röstaromen bekomme
und gleich darf ich sie im Backofen noch garziehen.
Jetzt im Prinzip alles andere – Kartoffeln und Paprikagemüse.
[Musik]
Ihr könnt das auch gerne einmal durchrühren.
Dann den Deckel draufgeben.
Im Backofen darf es bei ungefähr 160°C schön schmoren.
Das ist ein Schmorgericht.
Dadurch wird es auch schön zart und saftig.
Das Gemüse darf langsam vor sich hin garen
und es wird wunderbar aromatisch.
[Musik und Uhr]
Jetzt sind die zwei Verkosterinnen da: Samira und Ela.
Ich hatte das Gericht jetzt 1,5 Stunden im Backofen.
Ich würde es aber tendenziell eher 2 Stunden drin lassen,
also da kann man auf jeden Fall nichts falsch machen.
Jetzt probiert einmal.
ELA: Elas Topf!
SALLY: Der Ela-Topf, ja! Ich habe mit der Ela diese Rezept gekocht.
Und? Schmeckt es euch? [Samira stimmt zu]
Ich probiere auch einmal ein Stück.
ELA: Kochst du immer sowas in diesem Topf?
SALLY: Ja, manchmal auch Nudeln oder Reis oder nur Gemüse.
Was ist dein Lieblingsrezept?
ELA: Das!
SALLY: Das da? Fleisch mit Kartoffeln? [Ela stimmt zu]
Sind die Kartoffeln schön weich?
Sehr gut!
Ich habe eben schon abgeschmeckt und probiert.
Was ich dazu sagen muss: Wenn ihr das Rezept kocht,
dann darf die Sauce anfangs schon sehr würzig
und leicht versalzen schmecken,
denn die Kartoffeln, das Fleisch und das Gemüse sind nicht gewürzt.
Die nehmen das Ganze dann gut auf.
Oh ja, jetzt ist es schön weich.
SAMIRA: Also mein Lieblingsrezept ist das da hier.
Wir haben auch schon einmal in der alten Wohnung dieses Rind gemacht,
weißt du das noch? Das Gezupfte.
SALLY: Der Schmorbraten, gell? [Samira stimmt zu]
Also wenn Kinder noch einmal nachschöpfen, dann schmeckt es gut.
Ela mag nur keine Paprika, aber die mochte ich als Kind auch nicht,
vor allem, wenn sie schon weich waren.
Wie gesagt, probiert das Rezept gerne einmal aus.
Ich finde es vor allem gut, wenn man da jetzt
ein frischgebackenes Brot oder Baguette dazu serviert,...
SAMIRA: Nicht alles!
SALLY: ... denn das passt da perfekt mit dazu.
Vor allem kann man mit dem Brot auch noch in die Sauce hineintunken
und das ganze Rezept oder Gericht lecker genießen.
Ist auch ein tolles Rezept für den Ramadan, gell?
Kann die Oma auch gut kochen
oder wir kochen es für sie und laden sie mit dem Opa ein, ja?
Also viel Spaß beim Kochen.
Alle Rezepte findet ihr natürlich in meiner App
– in der Sallys Welt App –
oder auf dem Blog auf Sallys-Blog.de
Dort gibt es auch eine Ramadan-Kategorie
– könnt ihr auch gern vorbeischauen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Schreibt gerne in die Kommentare,
welches Rezept ihr euch noch wünscht.
ELA: Und wenn ihr was zum Valentinstag machen wollt,
könnt ihr einfach mal so eine Sauce machen.
Und dann nehmt ihr einfach Puderzucker und Wasser
und dann könnt ihr noch die rosane nehmen...
SALLY: Aber Valentinstag ist erst wieder nächstes Jahr.
ELA: ... und dann noch schmücken mit...
SALLY: Schmücken mit?
ELA: ... Herz!
SALLY: Aww, okay.
ELA: Mit einem Herz und dann Streusel.
SALLY: Gut, aber komm, jetzt setzen wir uns an den Tisch
und essen mit Papa zusammen.
Komm, du kleine Maus!
ELA: Manchmal frage ich mich sogar, wo er ist.
SALLY: Wie bitte?
ELA: Wo...?
SALLY: Ach so, wo der Papa ist?
Ja, das frage ich mich auch den ganzen Tag. [Lacht]
Komm her! Komm kleiner Baby-Affe, ich nehme dich auf den Rücken.
Nicht, okay. Und hopp! [Lacht]
[Musik]